buenos dias
buenos tardes buenos noches
happy may 5th everybody that's right
it's may 5th 2021 i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report message direct
message and
it is cinco de mayo so wherever you are
i hope
you're drinking some tequila preferably
while you're watching because
it makes the stories all the more fun
and we're gonna get to a lot today
uh the main story we're gonna be
covering is this trump
ban on facebook because the overlords
the overwatchers
at facebook have decided to continue
trump's
ban for another six months and then
they'll revisit it and it's like who's
more powerful
is it the 19 people on the board that
decide whether the former president can
speak or not
or is it the guy who's just trying to
get his voice
back so we're going to focus mostly on
that story but with that in mind before
i tell you
about the other stories we are going to
cover i decided
to do a little something today because
uh
we are completely at this point i would
say completely
at the mercy of these big tech overlords
and until
we basically develop new products and
figure out what our off-ramps are this
is never going to get better right the
government
there's this endless debate that
everybody's always having okay section
230 okay can we break them up okay
antitrust okay free market like we can
have those debates forever but until we
actually do something which
is what i'm trying to do with locals.com
uh nothing's ever going to change if you
think the government's going to fix this
problem
the government which is worse than
facebook if you think they're going to
come in and now it's run by democrats
who gladly would keep trump off and keep
most of you off and keep me off and
everything else
it's like they're not going to fix
anything they didn't fix it when they
had the power and trump dropped the ball
on that and the the republicans
in the senate again guys you know i say
guys that i like like
uh rand paul and ted cruz people that i
like drop the ball they do a lot of this
theater stuff nothing's ever going to
happen
but i do believe in free markets and i
believe in technology and that's exactly
what we've done with locals.com so
today only this is only for today if you
sign up
annually at reubenreport.locals.com if
you sign
up annually first off you get two months
free we always do that
if you do the annual subscription uh but
if you do it
today and then forward your email
when you get the email confirming that
you've signed up if you forward that
to support reubenreport.com
i will personally sign one of these
don't burn this book
note pieces of paper for you it will
include your name
your name and my signature
there you go and i might even write
thanks or something else snarky
or fun or interesting you never know so
all you have to do
is go to reubenreport.locals.com or you
can go to rubenreport.com
support and if you sign up annual
membership just forward that email we
get you
uh to support at reubenreport.com we'll
send one of those out to you and i think
you'll see something just
very very different happening on our
locals community than is happening
elsewhere on the internet okay so we're
gonna obviously talk
about trump and facebook and then trump
launched his new platform
which isn't really a platform it's a
little bit of an odd move by trump but
we'll discuss that
then coca-cola you know about these
people they send out these sugary drinks
to make us all fat and diabetic
and then they have some other stuff too
um they were bringing in diversity
training and then there was pushback and
now they're getting rid of it so it's
like they were kind of admitting they
were racist but then
they saw the dollar signs and now
they're saying we're going to get rid of
that so now they're just racist who like
money i'm not really sure we'll discuss
all that
and then finally we got a bunch of clips
about covid because this fouchy guy this
fraudulent fouchy guy
is now talking about kids at camp
wearing masks
he's now saying we're in the sixth
inning that's what he said to wolf
blitzer we're gonna play the video in a
little bit
we're in the sixth inning of kovid guys
it's a year
and a half after two weeks to flatten
the curve and this ridiculous
showman this fraud fouchy
now it's we're in the sixth inning and
kids should be wearing masks while at
camp i mean it's completely deranged
stuff so we are gonna get
into all of that and as i said i hope
you're having a wonderful cinco de mayo
i hope you're drinking
tequila or at least a corona while
you're watching
and before we get to any of that i want
to talk to you guys about raycon
you know as you guys know once a year i
like to go off the grid
for the month of august after spending
the last year cooped up at home i never
leave my house actually
i'm excited to be traveling again and
looking forward to a real summer
vacation
whether it's work or play a lot of us
are going to be on the move again this
summer hallelujah
so my advice is that you should take
your ray cons with you whether you're
catching up on reuben report episodes
i've got my raycons right here
or powering through your workout with a
pumped up playlist a pair of raycon
wireless earbuds in your ear can make
all the difference and look these things
are freaking tiny and they fit
you get crisp powerful beats at half the
price of other premium audio brands
raycons look great and feel even better
they come in a range of
cool colors and with customizable gel
tips included for a comfortable
in-ear fit and raycons are built to go
wherever you go with quick and seamless
bluetooth pairing and a compact
charging case i use them when i'm doing
cardio people
raycon's offering is 15 off all their
products
for my listeners and here's what you've
got to do to get it go to buy raycon
dot com ruben then you'll get 15 percent
off your entire recon order and it's
such a good
deal you'll want to grab a pair and a
spare that's 15
off at byraycon.com reubenbyraycon.com
reuben and now back to me okay so the
big story that is sort of lighting up
the internet while the internet can
still be lit up because who knows how
many of us are going to be on it in a
couple years if this all keeps going in
the direction it seems to be going
uh the big story is that the facebook
oversight
board a group of 19 people have decided
to uphold the suspension of the scary
orange man
uh we've got a quote from the associated
press
the social network's quasi-independent
oversight board
voted to uphold his ban from the
platform after his account was suspended
four months ago for inciting violence
that led to the deadly
january 6th capital riot but in a
statement it faulted facebook for the
way it made the decision and called its
indefinite suspension of trump
unreasonable and unworkable so before we
go on there we've got some quotes from
some of the
people on the board now again this is 19
people it's a quasi-independent board i
don't know what that means now
facebook's entitled having a completely
non-independent board it's their company
they can do whatever they want but
quasi independence seems weird and what
is it it's called the overwatch
oversight i mean it's right out of 1984
right like
come on man this is just orwell would be
proud
he would just be looking at this stuff
going man i really did nail it
um but in essence what they did was they
said originally when they banned him
they said okay we're getting rid of them
all together and as i've said many times
it was a digital assassination and we
all watched it in front of our eyes and
we let it happen
very similar to what happened with alex
jones and that's not a commentary on
anything alex jones has done or said
or even what donald trump has done or
said right it's like we just watch these
people just get taken out
there's all sorts of bad people online
there's all sorts of bad activity
there's all sorts of mean people
and racist people a lot of them are blue
check journalists who are progressives
who are often very very racist
i just asked tim scott but we watched it
happen and we didn't do much now
i will give facebook a little bit of
credit here because at least
they went through the theatrics of this
which is bubbling up the conversation
again i didn't expect you know
over the last couple days when people
are saying okay wednesday's the day
that the facebook oversight committee is
gonna decide the fate of donald trump
like are they just gonna
push him into the pit of sarlacc or are
they gonna
you know whatever like it's just so
ridiculous but i will give them credit
in that they didn't have to do this so
the idea that they
met and did this so that it makes news
again it gets us all talking about it
again so i am seeing a lot of people
talking about free speech related to
the big tech platforms where the
government's involved
and everything else so in some regard
just keeping the conversation going
is good we've got a quote from one of
the board
co-chairs his name is michael mcconnell
very powerful man
he says indefinite penalties of this
sort do not pass the international smell
test
we are not cops reigning over the realm
of social media
except michael you are cops reigning
over the realm of social media that's
quite literally what you are you
reign over who can be on these things
and who can't be on these things
now there's no doubt that there are all
sorts of
awful dictatorial people probably many
of them in the middle east
who are on facebook we know ayatollah
khamenei is on twitter
we know that bad people are on these
things and we can have all sorts of
debates about whether they should be
allowed to be on these things and what
actually qualifies as a direct threat
we also know and maybe this is the key
to the whole thing if you if you take
nothing else
from this story that the january 6th
capitol hill riots protests violent acts
whatever you want to call it
more of it was coordinated on facebook
okay don't take my word for it do some
googling
okay you guys have got the google at
least for now also
uh more of the coordination of what
happened on january 6
was done on facebook than was done on
parlor but it's very odd
that the big tech people and the amazon
people didn't blow up the facebook
servers they blew up the parlor servers
and the reason of course for that was
that parlor was the outsider parlor
didn't have silicon valley money behind
it
parlor had 21 million users
most of whom were obviously law abiding
decent people who were non-violent and
everything else
but 21 million users i can tell you
somebody that's running a tech company
right now that's an
awful lot of users to be able to get to
a new platform it's almost
impossible these days and basically
the the tech gods were like all right
let's just take out the competition so
they just blew up the servers in effect
but more of the violence if what you're
concerned about is donald trump and how
he coordinates violence
even though he told people to be
peaceful and everything else if that's
what you're really concerned about you
might want to take a look at a mirror
right like that's maybe what you would
want to be doing
but at the same time as all this was
happening just yesterday
donald trump who's been promising this
new platform and i've been asking around
right i've got
i've got some connections and especially
now with with the local stuff i have a
little more
insight into what's going on in the tech
world and how to build things and who
actually can build things
and all of the the philosophic and
technological principles behind it and
everything else
um so there's been talk over the last
couple weeks and months that donald
trump was going to launch some sort of
platform at some point it seemed like he
was maybe going to do with mike lindell
the pillow guy who actually did launch a
little something that's just sort of a
marketplace it looks more like an aol
website from years ago i like mike
lindell
but that that thing sort of is what it
is
uh but donald trump did release his new
site yesterday which a lot of people
were calling a platform
but let me read this to you from fox
news former president trump launched a
communications platform on tuesday
which will serve as a place to speak
freely and safely
and will eventually give him the ability
to communicate directly with his
followers
the space allows trump to post and
allows followers to share the former
president's posts
to twitter and facebook however the new
platform does not have a feature
to allow users to reply or engage with
trump's post okay so first off let me
say this
i know how difficult it is to to launch
anything in the tech world
and you don't just launch everything at
once so for example we've launched a
great set of features
on locals and we've built our video
player and audio player and we have a
great news feed in live chat
but like for example we're just now beta
testing live video streaming and it's
going to be tested at my community first
and then we're going to
move on to other communities so it takes
time to do all these things so the fact
that
trump's site is very scaled down i don't
think is
is too much of alarm however they they
did nothing here i mean in essence trump
has a blog
right like this is just like he can post
things and then you can click a button
to share it to twitter or you can share
it to facebook which is exactly what a
blog that you could have signed on
for like a blog spla bog blog spot blog
uh you know like 20 years ago so in
essence that's what it is so in no way
is this a
platform because no one else can do
anything there now they are saying
they'll eventually have some features to
allow people to reply and engage and
everything else
so i don't want to be too critical of it
but but it shouldn't be framed as this
is a platform all this is a blog he
wants to get his his word out there
now of course what he also has to
realize is you know twitter and facebook
could just
you know basically go into the api and
cut off the ability for him to allow
people
to post the stuff on their platforms
right because right now he's just got a
button
if you like what trump says you can
click that button it's going to go over
to twitter it's going to go over to
facebook
they could just say okay we're not going
to allow that site to do that so they
haven't solved any technological
uh problems here they haven't figured
out any of the litany of issues
that are there but it is a first foray
and i bring that up within this facebook
story because it's like the guy's trying
to do something
i'm not impressed yet but i also know
that these things take time so we shall
see
anyway to wrap this all up in a nice
little bow
um the point here basically is that
if big tech is going to wield this
extraordinary power over us
then we all have sort of limited amount
of time to figure out what our off-ramps
are i think you know what my off-ramp is
at this point i'm not trying to make
this a commercial
but we all should be thinking about this
you know these things will not last
forever unless we give them the power
to last forever remember myspace
remember aol these were ubiquitous
things that we all thought were all part
of our lives
that were never going to go away and
eventually they do go away and i suspect
there's so much happening right now in
the crypto space
blockchain space there's so many new
tech companies
bubbling up all over the place i think
i've mentioned it on the show we're
moving locals to miami which is now the
new
tech hub of the united states there's so
much happening that you know if we just
divert our attention
away from these platforms that
eventually they'll crumble and then
it'll be
10 years from now it'll be 20 31 and
we'll be looking back on man you
remember
remember all that time we used to spend
on twitter that evil hellscape of an
awful website where everybody was trying
to destroy each other like what kind of
self-imposed mental institution
were we really putting ourselves in like
that's the way we're gonna think about
it and i really think that's the same
thing that will happen to facebook it'll
be like what
you were on facebook.com where you
didn't own any of the stuff and they
were selling
your data and you were the product and
you kept posting
personal pictures there and it was
unclear who controlled any of that
information and you knew
that they were manipulating you with an
algorithm that was showing you
political pictures and baby pictures and
grandma pictures and terrorist attack
pictures
and it was making you crazy and it had
infinite scroll to make you really
bananas like
i think there is a way off all of this
stuff but that way involves a little bit
of discipline on our
behalf which is maybe don't use them as
much and i say that with all
do irony because i still do use twitter
um
but maybe don't use them as much and
figure out what what it is that you want
what is the nature of the relationship
that you want with the internet i think
that's what this is really about
is like you know people think we have to
be on these things to function
and i'm starting to think we really
don't and and the highly functioning
people won't be on these things you know
it's sort of like
when you hear about all these tv
executives or big tech people
all these super rich people that don't
let their kids have phones why is that
they don't let their kids watch tv why
is that maybe they're on to something
maybe they know they've been peddling
drugs to us
and and now we're the addicts and they
just keep giving us more and more while
they
basically don't you know play in the
game that they're you know basically
forcing us to play and you think it's
something to do with that or am i a
crazy conspiracy theorist
who should be kicked off facebook we'll
leave it up to the oversight committee
all right guys let's move over to the
second story so coca-cola
has paused its aggressive diversity plan
after their chief lawyer resigns this
story is so bananas and it's such a
perfect
example of everything wrong with social
justice and
the evil marriage that it now has with
our giant corporations so this is from
the new york post
coca-cola has paused its controversial
diversity plan that included penalties
on
outside law firms if they failed to meet
racial diversity quotas
after intense backlash so let's just
pause for a second before i continue
did you catch what i just said there
coca-cola was going to
actually punish companies basically not
work with companies
if they decided that they wouldn't have
racial diversity quotas
it's funny i thought quotas were bad i
thought saying oh we should have this
many
people because they're white that would
be bad and this may be because they're
back because they're bad and everything
else but coca-cola ingested
these horrific ideas of social justice
and they were going to not
work with companies that did not have
the racial diversity quotas that they
wanted so okay
now that you got that the pause on this
ridiculously horrible policy comes after
the orchestrator of the plan
koch's former general counsel bradley
gayton
abruptly resigned last month after less
than a year on the job
and as criticism of the quote is mounted
some questioned whether gayton's
policies violated title
vii of the civil rights act of 1964
which says employers can't treat people
differently
based on their race yeah that whole
civil rights act
remember that civil rights act thing
that we passed because we didn't want
people to discriminate so we didn't
want quotas we wanted to make sure that
the government wasn't going to
discriminate and actually in terms of
the civil rights act that companies
weren't going to discriminate
and then what happened flash forward
from 1964
to you know 2021 flash forward you know
those
55 60 years whatever it is and it's like
oh
now we want quotas and why is that
because as i always say
the anti-racists have become the racist
anyway
coke got real pushback on this there was
a ton of people online saying
i'm not going to drink coca-cola anymore
and by the way you're really
not that you need you know health advice
for me but you really shouldn't be
drinking coca-cola anyway it's something
it's how much sugar
is in a can of coke can i get a number
on that it's so
much sugar it's ridiculous if you were
actually
to see it i saw a youtube video once of
someone where they actually showed the
teaspoons of sugar
that go into the can of coke 39
grams of sugar in a 12 ounce can
of coca-cola like try to do 39 grams go
into your kitchen after this
and and measure it yourself in a
measuring cup what 39 grams of sugar are
and try to imagine that that's what
you're putting in yourself in a 12 ounce
cola can
i'm probably gonna get killed by a big
coke now um for for talking about this
but and actually in america it's even
worse than just sugar because we we
don't even use sugar in ours
we use high fructose corn syrup which is
a easier way a cheaper way
of making sugar so you have to get a
mexican coke happy cinco de mayo
everybody you have to get a mexican coke
actually if you want real sugar a lot of
people don't know that
there is not real sugar in our cans of
coke but anyway that that's a
sidebar to all of this which is that
this story is so hilarious
because a giant corporation decides to
institute racism in the name of
anti-racism have
companies that we work with will have to
have racial quotas this is what the bad
guys would have done in the 60s and the
50s right
they do it then the market speaks right
this only is because of the market like
this guy waking up the lawyer
the legal counsel there him waking up in
the company reversing has very little to
do
with someone realizing that these are
horrible ideas
it's like oh actually somebody in sales
started looking at the numbers and
they're like holy [ __ ] do you see what
has happened guys since we announced
this
in the two weeks since we announced this
anti-racist policy
people are angry and they're not buying
coca-cola and again you should be
drinking water
actually they don't sponsor me but i'm
gonna show you what i drink
okay can i do this i can do this why not
i got though go ahead
i got spin drift here okay spin drift
it's just
soda water with a tiny bit of uh
fruit basically 15 calories what do we
got here
four carbs and yeah
zero fat anyway the point is there's
basically no sugar in here it's a little
bit of
pineapple juice in this one i'm enjoying
a nice pineapple spin drift this is not
an ad
i would be happy to promote you guys i
drink a ton of this stuff but if you
want something with a little flavor and
some bubbles
there's other ways to do it besides
coca-cola you also could just get
club soda and put it i mean that's what
i do sometimes you just get club soda
and put a tiny bit of lime juice in
there that'll work too but again all of
that is a sidebar
to the ridiculousness of these companies
which is okay
we're going to do something in the name
of anti-racism because we're good guys
then
we're going to get pushback because
we're going to realize that it's going
to hurt our bottom line and now they're
getting rid of the policy so are they
say
are they basically admitting well
actually we are for racism now
we're for racism but we're also for
money so we're gonna have to run with
this thing i mean it's
just so bananas don't drink coke
okay let's move on kovid speaking of
bananas
uh fauci you know about this uh this
fraud this guy is just
drunk on power the most highly paid
person
in the federal government that is
correct can we get the exact salary i
believe it's over four hundred thousand
dollars a year that's what fauci is
making
from the federal government i don't
think he's ever in the lab as far as i
can tell because he's basically just a
media [ __ ] at this point
well he went on wolf blitzer who was a
humanoid robot on the fake news channel
known
as cnn and they discussed uh
what's where we're at where we're at now
remember a year and a half past
two weeks to flatten the curve but they
discussed where we're at in this fight
against copenhagen oh and just to be
100 clear fauchi makes 417
thousand dollars uh in 2009 so he he
doing okay let now let's watch fauci and
blitzer
before i let you go dr fauci you and i
are major league
baseball fans uh what inning are we in
as far as this covid pandemic is
concerned
well you know i i we're at least halfway
through
i i hope we're seeing and and i do
believe uh
uh wolf i'm not trying to be overly uh
enthusiastic about what's going on
vis-a-vis
the vaccine program which is so
successful but we've really got to not
declare
victory prematurely so we're in the late
innings
but it's not over that's the thing we
really gotta get people to appreciate
we're going in the right direction we're
seeing the light at the end of the
tunnel
but now is not a time to declare victory
it's a time to get more and more people
vaccinated just the way the president
said today we want to get to that goal
it's a doable goal and i believe we'll
get there so you think the seventh the
eighth inning or late innings
what anything you're talking about how
about the
the bottom of the six try that one i'll
go with the bottom of the six that's not
too bad
all right dr fauci as usual we'll go to
a baseball game one of these days thanks
so much for joining us
uh so you think the seventh inning the
eighth inning the ninth inning to
twelfth inning are we in the 46th
inning how many pitchers do we have left
on the bench are we gonna have the first
baseman
uh pitch in the bottom of the eighth
it's all so ridiculous first off i just
quickly on blitzer blitzer's not human
i don't know what he is i believe him to
be some sort of synthetic
humanoid robot that they put in the skin
of
a cnn news anchor and they put him there
and i if i'm i don't have any evidence
of this but i'm fairly certain he is
actually plugged in
to a long wire in the situation room
like that's what the situation is
okay the situation is that they've got a
fake news man there he doesn't strike me
as human but putting
aside whether blitzer is human or not uh
fauci
uh we're at least halfway there it's a
year and a half later what the [ __ ]
are you talking about it's a year and a
half later
everyone's ignoring this by the way the
traffic has come back in la
no one is listening to any of your
nonsense well i can't say nobody because
there are a certain amount of blue and
on brainwashed
people that are still listening to this
but everyone is everyone sane i would
say for the most part has decided to go
ahead
and live their lives functionally and
again that can include wearing a mask if
you so see fit to wear a mask and if you
want to get vaccinated you can get
vaccinated and all that
but the idea that he would say that the
implication the sixth inning that means
we're two-thirds of the way through this
thing
so we still have basically another year
of this thing it's never gonna
end it's never gonna end and the fact
that they're talking about it
with baseball analogies shows you how
unserious
these people are about these things what
did they mean what did they mean
a year and a half ago two weeks to
flatten the curve notice they never
mentioned the curve anymore what the
[ __ ] happened to the curve sorry i'm
cursing
but like what happened what happened to
the curve it's just
ridiculous and we can't declare victory
and guess what
they're never going to declare victory
because they love the power that we've
all given to them
they love that they can control us and
decide who can go to work and when they
can go to work and who can own a
restaurant now
and become a functioning decent human
being with dreams and passion and
everything else
that's what this is about this is a
freaking big ass test
to see what they can do to us next
whether they want climate lockdowns
or they'll just make you know they'll be
coveted six or
you know just whatever the uh imaginary
disease what was the imaginary disease
in uh
contagion what was that disease get me
that disease because they're gonna tell
us that disease was real
which by the way uh sanjay gupta the
doctor
uh and you know cnn's doctor he was he
played sanjay gupta the doctor in the
movie contagion
which was about this whole thing i think
we played that clip very early on what
was it it was some
the what does the some kind of something
other disease it was the
mev1 was the film's fictitional virus
sort of sounds like covid19 anyway fauci
uh then went on nbc to talk about what
your kids
can do this summer and um if you have a
punching bag i would recommend keeping
it nearby here we go
summer camps are coming up and a lot of
parents are looking forward to sending
those kids out and hoping they have a
great summer since they weren't able to
last summer
the cdc guidelines right now for kids in
summer camp say
masks must be worn at all times even
outdoors
by everyone including vaccinated adults
and children as young as two years old
and campers
should stay three feet apart even
outdoors my question to you is
given what research shows about uh
transmission outside about the low risk
of serious illness in children
are these cdc guidelines excessive
you know i wouldn't call them excessive
uh savannah but i
they certainly are conservative and i
think what you're going to start to see
is really in real time
continually reevaluating that for its
practicality
because you're right people look at that
and they say well
is that being a little bit too far right
now yeah because aren't we supposed to
be [ __ ]
we've been told people have been
preaching for a year follow the science
the science doesn't suggest those cbc
guidelines are too sensible for
little kids outside a 90 degree heat
running around with masks
yeah somebody you've asked me that
question a couple of times before
i'm asking for two kids named vail and
charlie age six and four
yeah well you're right the cdc makes
decisions based on science they will
continually
re-evaluate that you're right it looks a
bit
strict a bit stringent but that's the
reason why they keep looking at that
and trying to you know reevaluate on
literally in real time
whether or not that's the practical way
i'm sorry if you believe that guy at
this point i'll have what you're having
like because you swallowed the blue pill
and
you know ignorance is bliss like what
what is he saying first off i thought we
were just told weren't we just told like
two weeks ago
or 10 days ago that being outside
without masks is what they're telling us
to do that it's actually
okay and even here in bananas la i
started seeing more people
walking around without masks outdoors
now we're saying kids
we know that there's virtually no
transmission with kids we know this to
be
true so you want kids in summer camp and
savannah guthrie actually did a nice job
there you want kids in summer camp
in 90 degree heat to be running around
and playing basketball and doing track
and field and archery and all of this
stuff
while while they're wearing masks even
though we know kids aren't getting it
kids aren't transmitting it
at summer camp you're outdoors literally
all day i went to summer camp
my entire life there's pretty much
nothing indoors and you pretty even
even lunch you're basically you know
you're eating sometimes under some kind
of
roof but everything is outdoors and
obviously all of the counselors
are going to be vaccinated all of the
staff is going to be vaccinated
so what the high hell is this guy
talking about like
and by the way notice how everything he
says he says follow the science and the
cdc guidelines he gives you the
buzzwords he gives you the bumper
stickers but how about you tell us the
numbers
okay okay fouchy how about at this point
you tell us
um about these conservative numbers
you're discussing well how many kids
have transmitted to other kids in the
summer a year and a half
later how many how many how many kids
got covered
two weeks ago outdoors
that would be my guess that wasn't white
powers i apologize
it was just a that was a zero we used to
call this a zero
uh now it's thought of as as a white
power symbol
uh here we go congratulations media
matters you got your clip
uh all right but then if that's not
enough for you
uh presidential advisor anita dunn
went on cnn to talk about schools
reopening in september so we just talked
about what's going to happen in the
summer we're going to put these kids
i mean jesus christ we're going to put
these kids in masks have them run around
probably all develop social anxiety
disorder and pass out and all that stuff
but let but school certainly we could be
going back to school in september
of 2021.
anita president biden said in an
interview that schools should probably
all be open in the fall can you clarify
is it the
administration's position that all k
through 12 schools should be back
full in time in person learning start of
next school year
and is the biden white house willing to
push back on any teachers unions or
others who stake out any position
to the contrary not backed up by science
so jake one of the great accomplishments
of this administration and one the
president
is very proud of is that 80 percent of
the teachers and school personnel
in this country have now been vaccinated
if you recall a couple of months ago
we um the president made the
announcement that we were going to have
a special supply of vaccine
dedicated precisely for this reason now
he said probably
he didn't say absolutely but given the
science
if the vaccination program in this
country proceeds
if people do go get their vaccines
there he does believe that schools
should be able to reopen
in september and reopen safely following
the cdc guidelines
but he said probably he said did not say
absolutely because
we've all seen this since unfortunately
january of 2020.
it's an unpredictable yeah guys
schools probably
should open two weeks to flatten the
curve
yeah we're just gonna keep pushing you
morons
remember back in april la we're just
gonna lock you down
till august you all get it man these are
middle management awful bureaucratic
[ __ ] artists i don't know if elon
musk is watching the show and i know
he's doing saturday night live this
weekend so he's probably a little bit
busy
and by the way if we maybe we'll mention
it tomorrow a little bit further but
snl saturday live which it used to be a
comedy show years ago it's just awful
trash now i don't think anyone really
watches it anyway it's just the same
blue check journalists just write about
it over and over
nobody actually watches it but um they
snl
actually announced to their staff that
if they don't want to come to the show
that night including the on-air talent
because elon musk is such a right-wing
maniac basically
uh that they don't have to that they can
have their own basic safe space that
there will be a trigger warning in a
safe space i mean how
freaking absolutely pathetic so in any
event i i suspect elon musk is not
watching today because he's probably an
acting class or something
but i just want to make a plea to elon
musk which is take me with you
take me with you to the moon to mars
zeon
seven mustafar like i gotta i gotta get
going
i can't take much more of this you
understand a lot i can't wherever you're
going
i i don't even need a seat i will sit in
storage
okay i just i don't i'll bring my own
food and water
all that stuff i got to get off this
rock man these people are crazy
these are crazy people we are in the
midst of a zombie invasion there is a
mind virus
and you know you're our only hope you
already put a tesla
in orbit remember that like is that
thing still floating around i will move
to the floating around the t
remember that he put a tesla in orbit
just had it floating around or something
like that
like man please i i gotta go i can't do
it much longer you understand
everyone's absolutely insane except you
the good people watching this because i
know you're saying and i should say that
actually i think a lot more people are
saying and a lot more people are waking
up but man
man the crazy ain't going anywhere
people it
just ain't going anywhere uh however if
you would like a little sanity please
join us at reubenreport.locals.com and
as i said earlier if you join today only
i will personalize
a book plate for you a little note that
they gave us when
when don't burn this book came out i
will put your name i'll even write
something for you and i will sign it
we'll do it for
i don't know let's say 100 people today
the first hundred people that sign up
will do ah you know we'll just do it for
everybody anyone that signs up today if
you sign up annually
at reubenreport.com support
you sign up annually you get two months
free and
you just forward that email once we send
you the email
saying that you've actually paid you
just forward that to support
reubenport.com i'll sign one of these
for you and you'll be part of a
community
of sane fun decent good
human beings they still do exist guys
part three
of my interview with former south
carolina governor and former u.s
ambassador to the united nations nikki
haley is up
at reubenreport.locals.com and of course
the full episode is up there ad free
already and then on friday we'll be
doing a q
a tomorrow so if you want to get your
questions uh in on that that's also on
locals and then on friday we're gonna do
a panel all on canada because
if you're not paying attention to what's
going on on canada if you think that
fauci and these draconian morons
that we have here in the united states
if you think this stuff is bad in canada
they are they have extreme lockdowns
they still have curfews
they're arresting people on the street
uh viva fry who's a lawyer who i've had
on the show once before who's just
absolutely fantastic he's been fighting
it on the front lines and ezra levant
from uh the rebel who has been probably
the main guy
exposing all of the bs happening in
canada
he'll be on and then we're working on
the third panelist you know getting
getting emails out to these people in
canada can be tough
so we will have a third panel so that'll
be on friday and in any event enjoy
cinco de mayo i hope you get out there
have a margarita or a corona
or whatever it is you do you know what
you know what i'm in such a good mood
i said last week that you guys can't get
guacamole with your chipotle anymore
you guys can have guacamole today in
honor of cinco de mayo
what a day people what a day enjoy it
get out there
and alan uh reach out to my people
okay you can find my people and i'm
coming with you
we're going gotta go can't stay here oh
and by the way we're gonna play you out
to a little video that we put together
in honor of lord fauci dr fauci you and
i
are uh major league of baseball fans uh
what inning are we in as far as this
covet pandemic is concerned
how about the the bottom of the six try
that one
i'll go with the bottom of the six
that's not too bad
[Music]
you